[Music]
here's your money briefing for Tuesday
March 28th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
when people think about retirement often
the first number that comes to mind is
one million dollars in savings to live
on after their working years are done
but most of us won't retire with
anything close to that Wall Street
Journal reporter Anne terguson spoke
with people many of whom have retirement
savings well below a million dollars to
see how they're making do and thanks
very much for being with us thanks for
having me so Ann a lot of people dream
of building up a million dollars in
savings for retirement but in reality
where do people typically come in on the
retirement savings scale well according
to some of the sources that I rely on
heavily a typical family's 401k and Ira
Investments accounts come to less than
slightly less than half a million on
average in the Years leading up to
retirement or for some people in
retirement which is about 55 to 64 years
old so the typical balance is about
four hundred and thirteen thousand
dollars on average
so how does that change the retirement
picture for people yeah so there's
really nothing magical about a million
dollars I mean people have different
Lifestyles people spend more people
spend less you know one million dollars
can be insufficient for somebody who
spends a lot it can be more than enough
for someone who doesn't spend much all
things considered the less that you save
the more at risk you're going to be if a
situation comes along that is like an
unforeseen economic shock or a setback
in life for example maybe an unforeseen
health issue that requires you to spend
a lot of money
on a home health aide or something it's
going to be a much harder blow to absorb
the less money that you have to save and
I think also people who save less are
probably a little bit more at risk to
worrying about outliving their money
yeah you know who wouldn't want to have
a million dollars when they're set to
retire right but having less than a
million dollars far less than that is
more in line with the rest of us and you
and your reporting team you spoke with
people with Savings in that range less
than a million dollars tell us about how
they're getting by I felt like they were
all have really really interesting
stories they have very interesting lives
very fulfilling lives and I think that
they're all getting by really pretty
well I mean I need to emphasize that
when we focus on less than a million
dollars in savings and we include both
401K IRA and pension wealth in that that
savings number but we don't include
Social Security and all these people
have social security as well so that's
an additional source of income that
people have you know in some cases they
have home equity in some cases they
don't so you know when we look at
savings we're just looking at one slice
of what people have a very important
slice but Social Security is a very
important source of income for people in
fact the Social Security Administration
indicates that about 40 percent of
people rely on social security for half
or more of their retirement income so
that just shows you how important it is
and some of the people also have some
money making opportunities a lot of
retirees work part-time in retirement
and we spoke to one woman who has done a
lot of work in the education field in
the past and she is also a writer so she
freelances and has been able to
supplement her income that way so what's
the lesson here if your savings are not
at that magical million dollar number
well one lesson I think is that Social
Security is a really important source of
retirement income and retirement wealth
really and so people need to start
thinking about it very carefully there
are strategies that you can use to
maximize your Social Security including
working longer delaying claiming that
can actually get you a pretty sizable
increase in your monthly benefit and for
people who expect to live well into
their 80s it can be a very good move to
try to maximize that income and so for
people who are still working and who
might have anxiety about having enough
when they do retire what steps can they
take now to ensure that their retirement
savings will be big enough yeah I think
ways that you can do this are think
about how much you're saving and you
know in some cases maybe you can afford
to cut costs a little bit and save a
little bit more so that's always one
strategy another strategy that came
through from these interviews is to
think about your asset allocation pretty
carefully and you know we're sort of in
a turbulent time now in the markets so
in some ways it's a good test case are
your assets allocated to stocks in a way
that you're able to sleep at night you
know for some people they may discover
that they're very anxious and they're
nervous so it's important to have the
right allocation of access between
stocks and bonds because one person we
spoke to found that in 2008 he had
enough in stocks that it made him so
nervous that he sold his stocks right
after they went down and he never really
went back in the market that was sort of
a bit of a blow to his finances because
the market obviously did very well
starting in 2009 and for several years
after that so you want to make sure that
you can still participate in the stock
market and get the upside of that but
without having too much exposure which
can cause people to then
freak out and sell it all and then sit
outside the market when the Market's
going through like a good period so you
have to be careful about that another
great lesson I thought from another
person was
try not to get too preoccupied with the
balance of your savings right especially
if it's on the lower side it's probably
making you nervous if you're budgeting
and you're being very careful about your
spending you're doing what you can do
right so don't kind of sit glued to your
computer and watch your balance go up
and down every day that's just going to
make you very nervous it's just
nerve-wracking another lesson that came
through was to ask for help when you
feel like you need it one couple relies
on their son-in-law he's a doctor but he
knows a lot about investing and he's
very helpful to them and I think a
trusted source for help is always a good
thing to have on hand and lastly again
try to maximize your Social Security to
the extent that you can all right that's
Wall Street Journal retirement reporter
Anne terguson and it's been terrific
having you with us thanks for having me
and that's your money briefing I'm J.R
Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
[Music]
thank you